[Music]
when I was nine my favorite pastime
wasn't recess or radio games or even
sports
it was statistics that taught myself
alone in my bedroom
sorting basketball cards from best to
worst using the numbers on the backfoot
cards it was back then that I learned a
very important lesson of stats 101 that
I could make the numbers say just about
anything I wanted my childhood idol was
a basketball player named Anfernee Penny
Hardaway he played in an era with
perhaps the greatest of all time Michael
Jordan but this introverted 4th grader
was determined to build a statistical
model that proved that in fact Penny
Hardaway was the best player in the
world now there are several common
statistics on the back of a basketball
card the most important of which is
points per game several players
including Jordan averaged more points
than penny so I started with a different
metric rebounds per game and I
eliminated anyone who averaged less than
5 rebounds now this narrowed the pool
but some survivors including Jordan
still averaged more points than penny so
I narrowed even further with assists per
game but Michael Jordan remained but now
that year I knew that Michael Jordan
missed several games due to injury Penny
Hardaway on the other hand played in all
82 games surely I convinced myself
health and durability matter for the
best player in the world and I
eliminated anyone missing more than four
games and so after games played rebounds
assists Penny Hardaway finally led the
pack I call it the penny algorithm is
how I proved that my favorite basketball
player was indeed the best basketball
player in the world
simple indisputable statistics now 20
years later I can tell you that the
logic that the penny algorithm used is
actually quite similar to the logic that
your spam filter uses to keep your inbox
clean in fact many machine learning
algorithms transform our daily lives
using such logic but you probably
shouldn't trust a model built by a
nine-year-old and more broadly and more
importantly as I'll show we should all
have the healthy distrust for models and
algorithms take Amazon is hiring
algorithm abandon in 2017 for gender
bias this algorithm learned the
characteristics of Amazon's best
employees and applied that pattern to
hundreds of thousands of job applicants
the problem was that at the time
Amazon's top employees were
predominantly male so the algorithm
learned to discount female applicants
even when they've removed gender from
the model the algorithm learned to use
proxies for gender and discounted
applicants for phrases such as women's
swim team or attendance and all women's
school
now many people hope the objectivity of
machine learning will counter things
like gender bias in the workplace but
the truth is even machine learning
algorithms can be vulnerable to human
bias on a mission to fight bias an
algorithm is joy boom weenie an
african-american computer scientist and
the creator of the algorithmic Justice
League as a graduate student using the
same facial recognition software that's
in our phones today she noticed that the
algorithms that worked on her Caucasian
male lab partner did not work on her
dark skin or dark features the problem
was that the algorithm that the model
was trained on a data set that lacked
meaningful diversity and the result was
that the same algorithm that works
ninety-nine point seven percent of the
time on my face
works just 65 percent of the time on joy
now what we all hope that the technology
we create will have benefits that can be
shared by all people but even the
benefits of machine learning are
vulnerable to human bias last fall
consumers were outraged when Apple card
offered better terms to male applicants
than female applicants sometimes 20
times better even before collecting
relevant financial data such as credit
score or income the internet exploded
with similar such examples once this
story surfaced but the problem is
that those algorithms do exactly as
they're told they maximize revenue by
optimizing for things such as
click-through rate and engagement both
of which vary by gender oftentimes the
goal of our model obscures its
consequences and the truth is machine
learning algorithms can have significant
unintended consequences now this
technology has transformative potential
to lift billions out of poverty and to
accelerate human progress
like few technology's ever before indeed
it's why I've spent most of my time at
Stanford studying it but unlocking this
potential comes with risks and
trade-offs and knowing when to trust a
model and when not to requires that we
first understand these risks and
trade-offs but assuming you're convinced
to have a healthy distrust for
algorithms how then do we know when to
trust them here are three questions to
ask I call them Penny's trustworthy
Frehley number one what is this model
true of every model just like every one
of our perspectives is built upon
assumptions bias often lurks within
these assumptions number two who or what
is missing removing gender from an
algorithm does not prevent gender bias
in fact it's often how bias is found
measured and mitigated and number three
what are the consequences of this
algorithm any one of us could find
ourselves in a position through our
actions and decisions to prevent the
scaling of unwanted bias consider my own
experience while I was in the United
States Air Force I built a model to
predict how students would perform
through a nine-month flight training
program in the f-15 this model allowed
us to identify struggling students early
and investing them appropriately
as flight commander I mentioned one such
student that the model predicted with
high certainty just would not graduate
the program I knew this data better than
anyone I'd spent hundreds of hours
training this model myself but I also
knew that student as a human being I
knew he was a husband I knew it was a
brand new father I knew that he
struggled with air sickness on every
flight just as I had for years prior and
while the algorithm encouraged us to
give up hope
deep down I had empathy for him should I
trust the model or not through the rise
of machine learning and artificial
intelligence many of you will face the
same question of whether to trust the
model or not I decided not to but what
matters more than my decision is that in
the future each of us takes
responsibility for this decision and
ownership of the consequences but before
you decide
remember Penny's trustworthy framework
and asked to fail three questions
what's this true of what's missing and
what are the consequences because making
better decisions with algorithms starts
with trusting them less thank you
[Applause]
[Music]